[Musique]
un couple d'américains en vacances dans
le sud de la france a mangé à la
pataterie et c'était amazing sur twitter
steve raconte combien avec sa compagne
ils ont adoré leur expérience dans cette
chaîne de restaurants où la pomme de
terre est reine un enthousiasme
débordant pour son plat une pomme au
four savoyarde c'était la meilleure
patate jamais cuisiné je me suis fais
pipi dessus quand j'ai croquer dedans
c'est un bloc de chair
plus ta chair tendre et j'ai cru que
c'était un chef sans ray hé oui c'est
vrai c'est drôle en fait c'est pas aulas
et du corps maison
j'en ai vu des trucs à pas mal en termes
de de moisissures avancé or là
il s'appelle arnaud à damier et demi
dans une série de toiles ils
représentent des coursiers en fait des
livreurs de repas ici avec un casque à
la main et un sac isotherme posé au sol
la peinture est très réaliste quasiment
photographique magnifique il ya eu un
william wallace le héros ikos et
interprété par mel gibson dans le film
braveheart et il y à sa statue beaucoup
moins épique adami s'inspire des
portraits aristocratique de l'époque
mais ville les adapte version 2000
maintien comme vous pouvez le voir ici
cette peinture est intitulé nicolas un
livreur pose dans une pièce très
luxueuses avec des dorures c'est
certainement une voilà une
représentation un petit peu grinçante de
l'époque numérisés
[Musique]
je n'exagère pas sans alexandre je
n'exagère pas j'exagère pas de sel
d'accord ça suinte
mais regarde la gueule des tranches de
jambon au
excusez moi lâche yeux obligés de lever
un peu là voilà c'était quand même très
énervé sûr pour les gens qui comptent
user de se faire vacciner et
et donc là j'ai dit une phrase il va
falloir il va falloir sortir la boîte à
claques et
et aussi des conséquences sur le terrain
réel parce que j'estime que la politique
du poste sanitaire cette issue au
personnel on n'est pas tous d'accord sur
ça mais moi j'estime que à passer
l'écart n'est pas la meilleure solution
pour mener la vaccination ne suis pas
dedans à vis des obligations mais j'ai
donc dans les manifs quand je dis les
choses quand j'essaie de rétablir la
science c'est à dire de dire que le
vaccin n'est pas expérimental puisqu'il
est mis sur le marché moi je me fais
frapper
il n'a pas dit que ça perso je me tape
un vrai succès chez les patriots après
avoir dit sur cette liste il fallait
sortir la boîte à claques pour les non
vaccinés bravo alors ça c'est pas de la
violence ça me fait rire parce que pour
l'instant
les
signataires m vous pouvez vous la mettre
d'accord
au
sérieux
ces cinq ans déjà qu'est ce que c'est je
sais pas ça pue
gerber a choisi vous bien non ils vont
bien
j'espère je vais pas tomber malade tu
vois quelque chose d un truc au cou
c'est pas mignon cafal non c'est pas
mignon pied
après cette mise en bouche on a envie de
savoir ce qui se mijote dans ce four
alors
un homme est parti brouter de l'herbe en
suisse un britannique pendant trois
jours ils avaient crié je pense très
singulière puisqu'il s'est mis dans la
peau d'une chèvre ses peintures
pourquoi alors il est à droite ou à
gauche tu m'as dit c'est la vache
c'était sacré à la réunion dont je me
suis mis en
jade or j'adore c'est thomas frey et et
et les brutes et donc il s'est fait
mettre des prothèses pour pouvoir
émerger comme une chèvre j'adore alors
l'histoire ne raconte pas s'il ya fait
du fromage avec tout ça en tout 24 sûr
c'est qu'en tant qu'homme chèvres et je
dis que c'est plus facile de grimper une
colline que de la descendre un truc à
dire son nom elle sera en direct dans le
jt alors fusé l'émission de ruquier
d'ailleurs lui qui était très en colère
parce qu'il devait le recevoir elle a
préféré se réserver pour france 2 au jt
dimanche soir depuis rouen elle va
annoncer sa candidature depuis roi est
la belle et maire de paris et maire
c'est pas elle varois c'est pas possible
conseil balises
[Applaudissements]
je vais ensuite j'ai pleuré d'émotion
sur sa vie tu veux sur tmc salah
abdeslam qui est manifestement sur le
périphérique et la sécurité maximum qui
entoure celui qui est dans une de ses
voitures et nous sommes sur le
périphérique parisien qui fortement
embouteillée et notamment dans au niveau
de la porte d'orléans puisqu'il ya
beaucoup de travaux en ce moment dans
paris
[Applaudissements]
qui va se frotter les mains c'est d'être
ya plus non mais ça valait j'adore
il ya des mégots de cloche posé comme ça
sur le toit sur la tête c'est pas
possible par terre aussi en fait ça fait
10 de cendrier c'est un débarrasser une
poubelle c'est un cendrier c'est
je pense aussi un coin cuisine au
costume rouge à paris c'est sa plus de
partout
ah oui non mais là c'est pas possible je
peux pas vivre comme ça ce fils mais
c'est la caserne d'ali baba oui alors
sauf si alibaba est devenu pompier entre
temps michel onfray est sans doute l'un
des seuls philosophe qui s'est vraiment
écrire comme un romancier comme un
écrivain et 100 qu'est ce que cette
agréable à lire
que serait-il d'ailleurs les livres et
que serait la lecture sont les deux
brèves sont quand même un peu faux quoi
il ya toute une école pourtant
idéologiquement c'est pas c'est pas mal
bon média bernard lévy luc ferry comte
sponville sont des gens qui qui écrivain
français élégant et c'est une autre
façon de faire de la philosophie
aujourd'hui et j'ai encore le droit
d'avoir un avis sur ce que je lis ou pas
on
toi tu as envie de faire comme les
autres exactement parce qu'à un moment
donné voilà il pourrait y étiez pour qui
est quand même compliquée quand on vous
engueuler n'être pas content ce qui est
normal mais quand on vous fait un
complément à contempler c'est la vérité
qui m'intéresse dans cette aventure
c'est pas ce qu'on dit de moi c'est la
vérité je pense que factuellement il ya
une dent vous allez la vérité quoi
manger dit factuellement comme nouvelle
bête donné motors et quand je vous dis
que la nation philosophe sur ce joueur
je me donne tort vous écrivez bien c'est
un compliment je crois que j'ai passé
l'âge d'avoir des meilleurs amis pour de
vrai j'ai des amis clairement j'ai
plusieurs amis tu va choisir mon cousin
s'est pas tu es là tu crois il croit que